[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the late
hill pan show today we're talking how to
spot the next 100 x with a very good
friend of mine but before we jump in
this is powered by icon plus capital
their vc firm and it is sponsored by
block five so block fire actually
offering i think the most competitive
interest rates actually right now around
nine percent um maybe even nine and a
half percent on your stable coins so
i've left a link in the description and
in the body of the tweet so hit that you
also get 250 when you sign up so
definitely check that out so we're going
to be talking about how to spot the next
100x with a very good friend of mine so
don't go anywhere let's bring him in it
is the ceo of old coinbase shash gupta
josh how are you
i'm doing great how are you leah
i'm good i'm so excited to speak with
you um for those that don't know i feel
like we need to um explain the
relationship here so shash isn't just
another person in crypto shash is the
person that really just made me stay in
the crypto space so i was working in
crypto and then i left in i think 2019
and then shash reached out to me and he
basically dragged me back in and i
haven't left since isn't that right
yeah
probably one of the best things for this
space as well right like i always find
it
i always find it like something i need
to do is like not let people leave
crypto so that is something i find and
something and you were so talented
before when you were doing everything in
terms of journalism and all uh so i
found it a little strange that you were
planning to leave so when i spoke with
you i was like no you cannot leave let's
do something and uh yeah having you in
crypto is awesome now you've written a
book
you've like what 250 million subscribers
on twitter
something
[Music]
so
so shash to me is like kind of just like
the godfather of crypto he knows
everything um he's taught me so much and
so i really just wanna yes don't shake
your head so i just wanna make sure we
get all of that knowledge out and um
just get it out okay because this guy
knows unbelievable amounts of stuff
basically just a lot of stuff
so before we
no it's not pressure it's not pressure
no pressure
knows good stuff so we're gonna get out
of him today and we're gonna find out
how to basically spot the best trends
understand how to navigate the crypto
space d5 nfts gaming everything because
shash knows it i promise you so let's do
it before we go into this
tell us about your background
oh well for me like i i used to practice
law in india and then i was like i want
to understand more towards the business
side of things so i moved to singapore
started like working with the company
and then started a little startup back
in 2014
wasn't the best of ideas
then try to find a new industry which
was interesting you know and had sort of
money in it and was like a new industry
um so i looked at 3d printing ar vr ai
you know all that jazz and then
my sort of
ears and eyes fell upon cryptocurrency
in 2016 i was like this is fascinating
but not coming from a finance or
technology background i kind of knew
that you know it's crypto which is tech
and then
you know
currency which is like finance and i
knew i kind of had to work twice as hard
as anybody else to even understand what
was going on so
from 2016 to 2017 i was literally
like a
anthropologist in the space just trying
to understand you know how people think
about the space what is being built
where is the future of the industry you
know what what what's really
happening here and that probably was the
best thing i did
in terms of you know getting aware of
everything from a macro perspective and
then in 2017 when i decided to really
you know start figuring out how to
survive of it because i was living off
my wife at that point of time um
i was you know i was like okay
let's figure out what to do and i
thought i could do investing but i
really didn't have any finances at that
point of time
i could do trading but trading sound
like seemed like something which is
too much work for very little result
like it's not something which is for me
uh then you could work for an
organization but after spending a year
in the space i did realize that you
don't want a macro perspective like you
want a macro perspective you don't want
to sort of
be a bit tunnel vision and organizations
themselves were
you know people who were trying to
experiment with stuff funding was easy
because it's like a fringe space so you
can get money from crazy people for
doing crazy things and that's what's
happening right now even till date
but uh
that was another thing so what i decided
is like okay like i spoke to a bunch of
friends like
i spoke to a friend and we started this
youtube channel together called coin
buzz just like a simple way to
uh you know tell people what's happening
in the space as we understood it uh and
then i've been running that since 2017
uh we've we have about we just crossed
300 000 subscribers on the channel which
is like a super cool thing i don't know
why so many people are watching that
but i i love what i do it's been amazing
the journey has been excellent i've
learned so much i've met so many amazing
people uh money has been decent
especially this year it's been pretty
uh awesome to tell you the truth so
uh all in all like that's
like a pretty extended brief on who i am
yeah well major congrats on passing that
um youtube milestone so that's for guys
if you missed it that's altcoin buzz so
check their youtube out um they always
spot the top trends and i need to tell a
story so
shash told me over a year ago to get
into several different coins and i
didn't um i don't know why um i just
didn't and obviously um
i don't know what i can't even think of
come on name it okay god name it i told
you to get like into engine at like four
cents which is like three dollars 60
cents right now i told you to get into
you know quan network at less than five
dollars like four and a half dollars
that's like 288 i think it was actually
three and a half i think it was like
three and a half dollars at the time
yeah
and then i told you again to rent
protocol which was like under 10 cents i
totally get into chain link and only get
into
uh
one wait we need to talk about one
question
yes harmony
you told me to get into harmony um it
was it was like dirt cheap i had
literally
15 pounds in like a spare wallet so i
was like i'll throw it into one okay it
is now worth 700 pounds why didn't i put
more in shash
i don't know i i don't know that's on
you but here's the thing right
what what
here's the thing right like it it takes
a while it really takes a while to
start seeing this and
and it's fine like i've been
like you i've been totally opposite of
you and both are complicated like if you
don't take the risk you're in trouble if
you take too much risk you're in trouble
right like
like for example
we will get into the mean coin side of
things and what i really feel about it
as well yeah but uh like the best thing
is to sort of manage your risks pretty
carefully but that said like the other
coins that i did tell you to sort of get
into like chili's i was so bullish when
it was like well under a cent the things
gone to like it went to like 88 cents
like that was just insane
and yeah it sort of paid off sort of
throughout the bear market like from
2016 17 18 19 and 20 and then
march 2020 was like horrendous time like
the entire market crashed the
because of the whole stock market and
oil market crashing and it was really
bad and i think around that time is when
i decided to
double down on my efforts with altcoin
buzz as well and i was like okay it's
now whenever i go all in and like give
it my best shot and probably the best
decision asked you to join the team as
well i asked everybody in the team to
sort of uh you know get their act
together because i could sense it where
everybody was sensing doom i kind of
felt that that's going to be
the bottom uh of course it was really
scary right uh it was tough also because
at that point of time to sort of run
altcoin buzz it was we barely had any
revenue at that point of time so what i
had done is a little bit bitcoin that
we've saved and actually instead of
selling it because i was so bullish on
bitcoin i had taken a loan on bitcoin
had taken a left
nice all my bitcoin got liquidated right
like that was the worst moment ever like
i lost oh no
yeah it was pretty bad who did you go
through wait oh my god wait what what
what i had no idea
yeah it happened it was pretty bad like
i was pretty shaken up for a bit and
then kind of got my head together and i
was like well let's let's start all over
again and then i started all over again
yeah it was tough but worth it
yeah totally worth it because your all
your calls have been
essentially from what i know spot on um
but i want to understand how you spot
these
calls basically i remember you
explaining quant to me um a while ago
and you were like yeah it's like the
middle chain and then at the time i was
just like yeah i have no idea what
you're saying but i was like trying to
keep up but now tell me how do you spot
the these trends like how did you spot
harmony
all right so
at that point of time when
i got into harmony was
at a time when ethereum 2 was being
conceptualized and guys that harmony had
already
done the whole sharding bit and created
sort of what ethereum 2.0 was gonna be
and it was pretty clear to see that the
way even in a down market where a few
people were using d5 ethereum was having
a bit of a hard time to survive now
people love the decentralization of
ethereum but
if you can have something which is
less decentralized now but works but the
fees is much much cheaper
you'll be able to have much more
movement on it and that's why sort of
looking at layer ones that were more
efficient and layer twos uh like you
know matic etc that are gonna make
things better made complete sense and uh
because it was going to do well and
here's the thing right like my belief in
it was so so much
that kind of knew that everything around
it and everything that was trying to
kind of compete with it improvise on it
is going to do really well so i was
actually pretty bullish on cosmos as
well uh cosmos didn't perform as well as
i thought because evms which is ethereum
virtual machines they took over the
entire space in terms of you know the
development so like bsc came out with
its evm and binance chain was actually
based on cosmos tendermint sdk
right but they realized that it's very
hard to survive on the decks that they
had made which is called finance decks
and that was called chain at that point
of time they instantly kind of went to
binance marching which is a different
chain all together and that's when i
realized that the evms and those
ethereum based ones will start
performing better so it was easy to see
why something like a matic a harmony
a bsc etc will start performing fairly
well simultaneously
you know when these started doing well
other chains that had
somebody backing them like for example
uh bsc is backed by
binance uh then there is solana which is
sort of backed by ftx right and
ftx is another beast out there right so
if they're gonna support a chain it's
gonna do really well so it was pretty
easy to see from that perspective but
but the the question you're asking like
how do you identify from starting up
right and one of the best ways is
figure out what you use in the first
place so the first thing is things that
work so there are two types of
investments current projects and then
future speculations right
so when you look at current projects
it's like i have already built something
so if you are going to use it and you
like using it then
simply because
you know you should consider yourself as
an average user at that point
yeah at that point when you're testing
it out
and then when you when you kind of play
with it and you like it for example
that's what happened with me by nance in
2017 right i ended up buying binance
coin for 40 cents simply because it was
uh something i wanted to use they had
about 200 000 users i remember it was
october of 2017 and it was just launched
like a few months back it was gaining
traction and they were listing all the
hot coins at that point of time that i
wanted to trade buy etc so i just got
into finance and i love the idea that
you could get 75 discount on fees at
that point of time you could get 75
discount i was like that's amazing so i
bought some bnb and i realized i used to
pay initially like sometimes between
five to eight bnb for a trade right like
it was just crazy because it was so
cheap
and uh then
like that became like a fairly decent
investment for me and i didn't even want
to look at bnb as an investment and
eventually realized
you know okay wow if you use something
using something then others are going to
use it there will be far more
speculation on it
sort of that kind of got me into
understanding the use cases for stuff
like chain link so interesting use cases
for projects that are having a growing
user base
it's an easy buy
for example uni swap is one of the
easiest buys out there like when uni
swap token was launched i was like you
can go all and you will never sort of
you know get into any issues because
uni swap is d5 like 95 percent of d5 is
pretty much uni swap right now pancake
swap is uni swap sushi office uni swap
quick swap is uni swap all other am n's
are pretty much uni swap in my opinion
so and you'll swap v3 is literally a
game changer people haven't realized how
amazing the tech behind v3 is like v3 is
far superior than v2 it's just so many
things need to be built on it v3 is
essentially like ethereum
for
trading and amm it just needs a lot more
tools to be built on it to really change
the skill the scope of things however
the big challenge that uni swap is
facing
is that
this stuck to ethereum and had uni swap
sort of looked at it from a broader
perspective and started launching
cross-chain solutions with
matic with uh
bsc with solana etc etc yeah then uni
swap would be the king out there like
literally there would have been the
entire d5 space can it do that
can it can it do that can it innovate
so multi-chain multi-chain is something
that can be done that means you can have
your product run on many chains
cross chains means that you can cross
liquidity from one chain to the other
which may not be mandatory in the
beginning but eventually there will be
tools that will exist that will allow
for cross chain uh as well
so having multi-chain and being like
okay we are also building on solana
we're building on avalanche we're
building on tezos we're building on
hashgraph we're building on bsc whatever
right is would have been fabulous for
uni swap they would have been
unstoppable in my opinion and i think
that's where sort of by bitcoin
maximalism or eth maximalism or any
chain maximalism sort of
kind of
narrows the focus of even project
builders that should be able to sort of
try and see you know how they could
attempt to do stuff
what i'm trying to say here is that what
what they did is not essentially wrong
but
it was their choice that
kind of allowed other projects
to do a lot more right like that's
that's what gave birth to stuff like
sushi swap or pancake swap or quick swap
etc and like hundreds of these swaps
which are essentially uni swap in its
nature so anyways the point i was saying
was that if you use stuff and you like
using it you should have their coins
because they're going to do well if you
use die
and you've taken the loan on maker then
maker is one of the best coins to buy as
well if you're using a launch pad
whether it's truss swap or ignition or
damage or an engine starter
start buying like those tokens because
if they're going to launch good projects
and you believe in the industry and you
believe in the capacity that's one way
of looking at it
the other way is more speculatory right
where nothing is being built
but we are speculating on things which
will happen into the future right
so at that point of time we start
looking at
the founders themselves have they had
experience in the past in successful
projects what have they built do they
understand product building do they
understand marketing do they understand
community building do they understand
communications do they understand
regulations compliance
all these things right so basically
three main heads come into force one is
product and technology
second one is regulation and compliance
and the third one is marketing
communications pr and community building
right
if if you believe that the founders
would be able to do that then at that
point when you're investing in a product
which is not launched you simply invest
in
in the fact that the founders will be
able to accomplish this so that time
you're
essentially investing in the abilities
of the founders
so this is sort of like a very simple
breakdown in my opinion uh
yeah if
i could go on on it but i'll stop here
no it's really useful and really helpful
um it's really interesting what you said
about um something that you actually use
so um because of you i use the crypto
com card and we were talking about this
before we went live because um crow that
their token or their coin is now up i
think 31 percent um in 24 hours which is
wild um so it's the same thing like i
i've actually decided to leave my money
and crow because i'm like hey i'm using
this thing
you know i'm enjoying the experience
they have amazing partnerships ufc um
formula one aston martin and all these
um other amazing sporting events so yeah
you're totally right um but i'd love to
get your thoughts on solana because i
just can't wrap my head around it
and some people say you know it's the
ethereum killer some people say well all
coexist um but they switched the network
on and off um the other day and that's
kind of concerning so that doesn't
really scream decentralization to me and
like you said you know it's backed by
ftx so talk me through solana where do
you stand on it
so
here is where the difference between
becoming from a user to an investor kind
of comes into play right
now i use a lot of products right
and if i see a product
which has problems which are fixable
but they're good at some things right
for example if if there is a tech issue
it's not like it cannot be fixed right
neck tech issues can always be fixed but
if they just don't understand
communication they don't understand
regulation compliance
setting up the right infrastructure
building a community
then i have bigger concerns at that
moment the point i'm trying to make here
is that
the the problem that solana has in terms
of tech decentralization etc you can't
look at it as an investment now you need
to see it can these problems be fixed
five years from now um
here's the thing right we're not in the
business of gambling if you're gambling
then this conversation becomes redundant
if you want to get today and come out
tomorrow then it's as good as getting
into a meme coin right and kind of yeah
that's how bimco investing works but
what we're looking is hey
am i safe with my money in this project
and will i make many falls keeping in it
in the next five years
can they fix these technological issues
or whatever issues right so every every
project has
many issues the bigger it gets the
bigger the issues become the more
visible the more transparent these
issues become so the question always
comes is do you believe that they can
fix it and as an investor
your job is not to speculate on the
present we are investing in the future
right we are all futurist
that's the way we should be working in
general right and because that is the
case if you use something now you work
it works fine here's the thing you think
using ethereum is a good experience
right now
it's not you think all these nfts we've
been buying it's like you've minting
faces like hundreds and hundreds of
dollars right now it's incredibly crazy
but
is that not bullish is that not a
problem that can be fixed imagine leah
if everything was fine and bitcoin
transactions were free it was completely
decentralized even more than what it is
now there is the opportunities for
people like you and me the reason there
is an opportunity for you and me is
because things are messed up
you realize that
no but now i do
if it was a hunky-dory for everyone
where would we make the money from
because they are not and because we see
it from a future perspective is why we
will succeed
and that's why keeping a long-term macro
vision is the best way to survive in the
crypto space because every time i see a
problem and i see people running away
is when i get to work and i realize and
analyze can this problem be fixed are
the founders smart enough to work on it
and fix it if the answer is yes
take all my money it's as simple as that
and i've done it so many times with
with like so much success that i can
kind of count on this formula
it's a very interesting perspective and
it's um
it's totally right actually because when
you i always say this the fact that we
are so early means there's so much
opportunity um and if everything was
sorted then
how can we innovate and how can we make
money um
it's true but in in terms of things like
um polka dot then
you know people are so bullish on it um
and i understand the whole para chains
um i understand the whole you know like
the octopus with all the all the
different chains and you know they can
they're all interoperable and so there's
less congestion and you know you can't
just like set up anything like you can
do on um ethereum you know anyone could
just create a meme coin um as an erc20
token polkadot requires um the auctions
and everything going on um
but you see i i find it difficult to
understand i understand what it does but
i find it difficult to understand how
it's different from you know solana or
something like that um and
you know and whether or not i should be
bullish on it i find that really hard to
really distinguish those differences
sure like i don't know what's the best
analogy to give here like i could kind
of think of something like
you know you have mcdonald's and then
you have gordon ramsay and then both of
them can do fairly well right
uh
but that said just taking polka dot for
an example
so there will be meme coins that will be
possible on polka dot it's just that the
meme coins won't be running on a
parachute
so what they've done is now
they they have gotten people to support
the creme de la creme projects by having
a crowd loan system which could in my
opinion cost somewhere between 50
million dollars to 500 million dollars
in terms of crowd support and dot
and then these projects will in turn uh
the people who support these projects
will in turn get
you know uh tokens given to them right
so one of the ones i am most bullish on
is called affinity uh it's a project by
the engine guys uh i've always been such
a big fan of engine that was pretty much
here's the thing i first mentioned my
first nft back in april april of 2018
and i knew exactly nft is going to be
one of the hottest things out there and
i was giving it free to our community
and people like i don't want your stupid
nfts like what is this energy right
but it it is what it is um the
experience was extremely good for me to
at least understand how you know you can
have these interesting tokens that can
be you know
made into art music etc etc so coming
back to polka dots so infinity is one of
those chains which i think is going to
be pretty cool if you stake your dot on
it and here's the thing now
the question is
don't don't don't look at it from
whether ethereum will be killed by
polkadot or solana whatever it doesn't
matter what matters is will ethereum do
well with solana do well will polka dot
do well and which one do you think will
do well the most right
so because there is no animosity between
the two because as as an investor you
can hold all three
so
why would you bother about like here's
the thing people think ethereum is gonna
you know beat bitcoin what the hell kind
of a statement is that like you have
bitcoin and you have ethereum and you
have solana so it's like you you're kind
of invested in the whole
industry in general so
and it'll be fun to see like here's the
thing if you're invested in all maybe
you know your one child does better than
the other child but at the end of the
day we're going nowhere we're here
to stay so
coming back to polkadot side of things
and this is where you know polkadot sort
of in my opinion
has shown pure genius is
every top project which is trying to
build on polka dot is getting their
entire community to not stake their coin
they have gotten them to stay polka dot
yeah yeah yeah which is ingenious like
which is just
really why would they do that
when they want them to stake their own
coin
now because only when you stick dot you
can get a para chain it's just sheer
genius oh i see
and because that sort of polka dot may
not perform badly even in the worst of
the bear market because if their
parachains do well and people start
using them
the dot
market is going to go kaboom like it's
going to do really really well simply
because
right now it's it's like i feel
i mean actually i had a very crazy
bullish statement regarding polka dot
but i'm not going to say it on yours no
tell us
what's it about can you give us a clue
no no it's something weird right like
it's something stupid very stupid to say
but i i kind of felt that
if any coin like the way the dynamics of
it were built
could beat bitcoin it could be polkadot
and if it works out right if the parrot
chain system just works fine people
start using it because you're not
comparing apple you're not even
comparing apples to oranges right like
bitcoin is digital gold
but
at the current moment
what ethereum and you know ethereum
competitors or friends whatever you want
to call them have become is more akin to
so if
bitcoin is like digital gold then these
guys are like amazon or google's of the
web 3 error right yes
and you don't say that hey google is
going to beat gold right you don't care
like that's not the silly thing to say
but sort of bitcoins legacy is
unbeatable that's never going to change
like bitcoin is always going to be a
king but
uh in terms of
really what polka dot is capable of
doing and if they launch a bunch of good
para chains
it can do fantastically well and i'm not
i'm not
like it's not really my biggest
investment or anything however analyzing
it is something that i felt the the
amount of power it can get and this will
depend on parachain launches if they
launch well and people start using them
and they start getting traction
then i will be mega bullish on it right
right now there are bit of ifs so that's
why it is a percentage because i'm
buying on speculation
but eventually when it becomes more
reality i'd be happy to invest more
in it
okay so just going back a sec you
mentioned that ages ago well not ages
ago a few years a few years is like it's
like 10 years in crypto um you were
giving out nfts um and you're really
good at spotting um those trends you
were going crazy um about d5 before the
d5 summer blew up i remember you were
telling me about compound and rv um and
i was just like ah what is that um so
um how do you how do you know what's
next um you know nfts
are the current thing
um and i do think that that will
continue i see a lot of value there even
d5 i think they'll continue but how do
you know what's next
well it starts with the basic
infrastructure level right so
what what can be done once it becomes a
reality the thing is
d5 literally started with make a dao the
moment you could lock in your ethereum
on a smart contract and take a loan on
it in a stable coin called die right
that was the inception of decentralized
finance that that actually started it
and when did that start when was that
launched i think maker dow started in
2018 if not before i think
18 yeah 18.
uh and ave was called etheland in fact i
was a part of a demo when ethel and did
its demo in 2017
and i was like this this stuff is weird
man this is not going to work and then
after following see here's the thing
right in terms of time
i felt
i felt like the d5 movement had happened
quite a bit by the time i got bullish on
it as well no way you are still waiting
you're still selling
it was it was the perfect time to get
into d5 and it was i'm glad i got into
that time but
uh in terms of trends i'd
by finding them early still very early
in a lot of trends and
and the nft subculture is nothing like
the crypto subculture
like nft
the ballgame is a different animal
altogether you cannot i have to spend
way more time
in understanding and analyzing nfts
because it's nothing like the crypto
space it
the the way the people are investing in
it the people are thinking in it the
whole mentality behind it
it's a separate subculture then crypto
absolutely different so the point i'm
trying to make here is that i have so
many interesting questions that i'm
still trying to answer and maybe for
some people it's just easy answers but
stuff like
the entire nft action is on ethereum
literally all of it
barely anything on solana though solana
is the second hottest
barely anything on matic even though
matic is easily accessible through open
c open c is the hottest nft why
why given it would be cheap it's
obviously cheaper right to do that
because it doesn't matter because an nfp
is valuable the more fees you pay on it
i guess i'm just saying i'm talking out
of my butt right now but
the point is that i i'm still trying to
figure out
this question why is there no nfd action
on bsc and
i i'm bullish on a lot of interesting
nft projects on and by nfp i mean art
nfds not game nfts game nfts is a
different animal altogether we'll get to
that later on but
the art nft side is just and it is such
a fascinating subculture the kind of
things that are being built on it like i
got extremely i studied about 180 nft
art projects last one month
uh and uh
the one that i loved the most was this
one called eponym
and it's 3d art right like it's
how it works is
when you could mint it when their
generation one was launched you give it
a word or phrase
and in within a minute it will design an
artwork for you
and if you spend time looking at the art
and the words you've given
you can't believe it's made by an ai
like it literally blew my mind wait wait
wait so you're saying i i would just use
this platform put in some words so say
you know i want to make like a political
piece or something i'd write like
freedom sovereignty
you know personal responsibility and
then it would just create some kind of
masterpiece yes i need to try this
yes no you can't do it because there is
no time when you can mint it so
it's smart like so what what they did is
for their generation one they had 10 000
pieces that people had to put in a word
or a phrase or whatever to be able to
mint
these nfts right and the artwork is
really fascinating it's really
fascinating like i spent some of them
are just garbage because they just
didn't turn out right whatever in terms
of design they weren't aesthetically
pleasing to me i wouldn't call them
garbage they just won
but that said some of the ones that
really appealed to me and they told the
story of the phrase written it blew my
mind as to how this is possible
and now they're doing something called a
generation two right
and the beauty is generation two you can
write more parameters what kind of a
texture do you want what kind of a
background do you want what colors do
you want there are a lot of things that
you can specify in gen 2 but hear this
to make one gen 2
you have to burn
two gen ones
like you literally have
two of generation one
nfts to make
a gen 2 now this is so smart because
the supply of gen 1 reduces
but then there are three smart contracts
that are taking place
one gen one being burnt
second gen one being burnt and the third
gen two being minted
and the piece is three times now so not
only do you have to
mint a gen two by burning two gen ones
which are already half an eighth each
like two gens
right that's like four and a half
thousand dollars plus minting fees on
top for three smart contracts
it's going to be so expensive
that
if they turn out nice they will be one
of the hottest most expensive projects
in the market what's the project called
again
eponym
yeah eponine e-p-o-n-y-m
hey i just have a few of them i bought
them very expensive of the market i
don't know those guys like i'm not
marketing them or whatever but i'm just
fascinated by it
that is fascinating
that is crazy i need to check that out
where do you see um
where do you see the whole nft space
going um
and also and also the metaverse
yeah are you bullish on the metabolism i
think
i think the nft side
right now there is a bit of a bear
market with the pfp sort of nfts which
is profile picture nfts in in a way
oh okay
so how do you find out that there is a
bear market like not really a bear
market there's a the floor prices have
gone down a bit i understand because i
think is going up
so the prices of because people are like
wow man eat is going to go nuts so
people
have started taking profits a bit of
their nfps so the nft market the profile
picture one's gone down a bit but there
are three types of basic nft markets of
the ones that i have analyzed one is
these profile picture nfts stuff like
kong's
uh punks etc
and then you have these art nfds which i
find super fascinating there are so many
collections that
are worth spending some time checking
out on and then you can also create
fabulous things like
there is this tool in which you can
design your own gallery and it's a full
like an individual metaverse sort of a
gallery that means yeah it's a free
space where all your friends can check
out your artwork and stuff that you own
uh it's called uh it sounds like uh it
sounds like terror i don't um it sounds
like terra virtua yeah
yeah yeah it's called on on cyber so
terra virtua is building its own sort of
a collector's den right in which you can
have it in a hangar like in a airline
hangar you can keep your artwork and
your you know their collectibles and all
the ieps that they have
terra virtual is fascinating but but
stuff like that is available on the east
side uh i did not know so i'm pretty
fascinated by it
uh but yeah the nft and the third type
of nfts is gaming blockchain
yeah so
gaming nfts are
are
super cool because it's like an nft with
a design but with the use case so there
is rarity in it but there is use case in
it as well and the future of these nfps
is that they are going to get more and
more dynamic in nature
so wait just i just want to jump in so
when when people like gaming nfts are
you literally talking about like swords
guns
um or
okay and are you also talking about like
um maybe characters or is it more just
like weapons and things like that
no it could be a blueprint of a level
oh no way it can be anything and and the
beauty of it is that it's dynamic
the future nfps will be very dynamic
that means leia if you if you played a
game and you had a sword in it
yes there is a chance that your sword
could have dynamic character to it that
means it starts deteriorating every time
you play with it so the color of it will
change and it will become old as well
and it's an nft at the same time that
means
the rarity of it the the online the the
blockchain nature remains the same but
the quality of it has increased reduced
aged etc etc
so a lot of these fascinating dynamic
things are being put into nfts but
here's the thing on each
every time you add a dynamic element and
you want to save it on the blockchain
there is a fees
element to it and that's why stuff like
infinity becomes extremely bullish is
because they're building the entire
thing and in fact they're working
closely with dr gavin wood himself the
founder of polkadot to build the
standardization of
uh the nft on polkadot and it's going to
be really one of the coolest things
which is what does that mean though
the standardization of nfts what does
that mean
so what we have in terms of
standardization on ethereum is two basic
standards which which are most popular
and nfts one is called erc720
called erc1155
and uh there is like a bit of
uh coding difference between the two
like you have erc20 for fungible tokens
right basically things with you know
yeah yeah limited supply which is one
equal to one but for nfts these two are
very popular standards
but because
on parity things can be much more
complicatedly programmed it's going to
be
far more dynamic and the kind of things
you can build with nfts on the polka dot
chain will be extremely extremely
dynamic and very very cool stuff is
going to happen
uh for the gaming side specifically
so uh
what was your question again but yeah
anyways so i'm getting excited about it
yeah yeah
yeah so um just for those who are tuning
in um
at the beginning of the show we were
talking about how shash gave me all
these different um tips for um tokens
and coins to buy um over a year ago
they've now gone to astronomical prices
and obviously i didn't buy them um but i
have bought um e5 because shash told me
to and i put quite a bit of money into
it so i was like whatever it doesn't
matter either i win or i lose but i
should do it so i've done it so i am now
inherently bullish on nft gaming stuff
so i'm excited for that um
let's talk about memes um are you in any
meme coins did you get the bottom of
sheeb or doge
the first rule of meme coin
for anyone is do not talk about meme
coins that's the first rule and simply
because
it's pure gambling right and
we we love to gamble and and by saying
that it's pure gambling it is pure
gambling so the point i'm trying to make
here is that
if you want to buy a meme coin like
especially when it comes to like even on
my old coinbus chat on telegram right
i'm pretty active then we're talking to
the community on a daily basis a lot
right
the only time i get a little old is when
people are talking about these random
meme coins and the reason is it's fine
you can buy them you can make money off
them if you're smart you should be doing
that
the only thing is don't get your
followers and people to buy them or get
into them because
they will definitely go to zero very
very fast like it's not zero maybe
maybe they will crash oh crash yeah
so so the point is that
do you wanna buy a meme coin is going to
a casino and putting you know all your
money on black or white whatever right
like it's just going and saying here is
my money you might win see here's the
thing there is a lot of ways to win uh
but it's just so much like gambling that
at least i have not been able to break
it down into science and if i can't at
least feel like i'm doing something
intelligent i cannot get myself to sort
of you know feel proud about it even if
it makes the money
yeah that's my answer to that no i think
it's great um so we've got a lot of
people tuning in right now everybody is
really enjoying um your knowledge
they're finding it really valuable um so
i figured that um it might be nice just
to give us maybe the top i don't know
five coins um obviously altcoins that
you're bullish on right now um
sorry to put you on the spot but
everybody's really enjoying um listening
to you and hearing and what you have to
say
so yeah what are like the top five
projects that you're bullish on
obviously you can repeat the ones that
you've mentioned
yeah of course like everything i'm gonna
say i i will hold
and i will
have like a bag of it for sure i was
extremely bullish on
i mean still am on cro uh when uh
you know when they announced their main
net coming and i've always been bullish
on it so that's one of the points i
really really like i've always been a
fan of affinity and engine since 2018 in
fact i've been in crypto.com which is
called monaco
uh since 2017 i've been in finance since
2017 i've been an engine since 2018
um
so these are some of those projects that
i've always been in and i've been in
fact even buying more and stuff and like
it's been a good journey holding on to
them
um
what else am i bullish on
so many there are so many amazing
projects that are happening i'm a huge
fan of uniswap uh engine just launched
their launchpad called engine starter uh
which is run by a team i'm i work very
closely with them as well um there are
tons of games that are launching on
engine starters so that's a project that
i'm super excited about and then that
said right like the point is find
projects that people intend to use if
you use launch pads
buy launch by tokens and if your
launchpad has problems
if it cannot be fixed right i'd say the
same thing again if these problems
cannot be fixed get out like sell it and
get out like it takes nothing to sell a
token and getting out of it
the problem is the investors spend so
much time holding coins with projects
that they have stopped believing in
but it takes a minute or maybe half a
day to sell whatever you stop believing
in and go to something that you do will
even
uh i'm i'm a big fan of polka dot so i
think that's super cool i love ethereum
for sure
i love many other projects that are
building on solana that's a cool
ecosystem silica is doing some fabulous
stuff i'm a big kind of chili's
like my portfolio might have over 200
projects so i can name them all and i i
love them all like my kid you know
what about avalanche what about
avalanche people are like shouting about
avalanche right now
i have yet to test too many things on it
it it's really cool but
there's only so much i have in terms of
capacity to test but we put out like in
terms of content that we put out on our
coin bus there's a huge research team
it's not just me or my ideas or my bags
that matter it's not the case
we cover a variety of things and
avalanche is one of those projects
harmony is another project we cover
very very often very regularly
and
if people are using so here's the thing
right if people are using it and the
number of users is going up
then it's it's already looking like a
good investment because user base is
equal to speculator speculation based
right where are you seeing these
comments though like i have nothing oh
you're not seeing the comments um
they're loving it everyone is loving it
i'm reading everything as you're
speaking um
i'll put some of them up on the screen
um
pn says what about matic
doug phantom
andrew jones avex is fast and cheap af
jamie says he's british on my channel
which is great everyone loves you um
that's nice look harry harry miller
really enjoys your your um your insight
great interview yeah i saw the comments
i was like sitting on this private chat
thing which was totally empty and i was
like where are you
here like russell he is smart shush is
smart
yeah thank god somebody somebody saw
through it
no you are um i want to just like
yeah no god what were you going to say
no no go what are you going to say
now people just think that i'm good
looking and i'm not smart so i don't
want them to be
it's both it's both come on um so let's
swerve a little bit um because one thing
as well which you taught me in this
space um was to have a macro perspective
not just um necessarily about um
investing but in times of business and
how to deal with people um and how to
kind of just like manage yourself and
your brand um
and uh you always you can't remember
what you said to me you said something
like
what did you say like dogs bark but you
said something to me and i can't
remember and just like not rising to
rubbish online and and just you know
create building good relationships so
altcoin buzz i know that you right now
you don't take sponsorships or things
like that you only talk about coins
which you're actually invested in um and
you're all about um
all you like right so but you're all
about like the ethics of things so talk
about the importance of um ethics and
therefore you know slowly building and
having longevity in this space
so here's the thing right like the true
power in crypto really is in the
community
the projects that realize that
uh wow i'm getting good comments that's
amazing thanks guys uh yeah i'm kind
bless you now sorry to distract you i'm
just putting them up
shash is a wise man yes sorry go on so
let's talk about longevity and ethics
yeah so at the end of the day
really like every time i feel like i am
getting bogged down by
a short-term mindset and i'm getting
scared and you will have those moments
where you're feeling like
everything's going to go bad things are
looking problematic there seems like
trouble
really looking into from a long-term
perspective listen to some of andreas
antonopoulos's videos
really like you know it becomes
extremely easy to kind of calm down go
into a bit of a zen mode and then look
at it from a long-term perspective i
have
i have really struggled through the
crypto space over the last four years
so many times
but every time i've only come back
stronger that means that there is a cost
of education that you have to pay to
survive in this space
the the market is extremely bullish
right now it is going to have a
correction right weak hands will get out
people will
feel like oh my god like i was so
excited then and then eventually they
will feel like you know oh you know what
did i do this means makes no sense and
all that fomo that they have will
instantly be created into fudd
the way to not create your fomo into
fudd is only one way to have knowledge
to understand what you're buying to
understand why you're buying it if you
intend to buy bnb
and you intend to use it and the price
goes down you can still be fine because
you still intend to use binance exchange
right but if you buy a meme coin that
you bought because 20 youtubers were
talking about it and people were you
know kind of shouting about these meme
coins and then suddenly they go down i
have seen so many companies people
influencers leave the space so many
times right
that
the best way to have a business is think
about how you build a community no
matter how hard the things is it's very
hard for us
and i've realized this it's not actually
hard but it becomes hard after a while
when you suffered so much by putting out
we started with very random content
right like in 2017 when we started the
channel
we didn't expect to grow it that big the
goal was just to have some fun right
like if you're bullish on something as
you learned you talk about it and
eventually we sort of matured we got
better analysts we got rid of like
people who would just make random
content but actual people who would
analyze stuff we would get into the
depths of things we will look into some
really
smart ways as to where the trends are
headed and now everything that we're
doing is very well thought out and
calculated in fact
our videos have finally started
performing performing much better is
because people are able to see that you
know some of the
some of the information which is out
there they they say abc is also good and
abc is also bad right like they say it
in both ways and then amplify whichever
ways it goes so we we try to just focus
on stuff that we're buying when we find
getting exciting for example we started
an nft segment on the website i'm not
invested in any nft per se except
epo name the one i just spoke to you
about right and that also i started
buying after two months of research
the thing is that i buy things after
months of research right
people buy after two hours or two
minutes of watching a youtube video
there is a bit of a difference
right there right and and if you're
going to buy something in two minutes
you will have fear of it in two minutes
also
and that's why bitcoin holders are far
better at holding bitcoin than altcoin
guys and that's why bitcoin
has more stability than altcoins for a
few reasons one
bitcoin has more regulation altcoins
have less regulation right
uh bitcoin has far more distributed as a
system all coins are not that
distributed right now and nor are they
that decentralized so there are these
basic differences between bitcoin and
odd coin but all altcoin takes
inspiration from bitcoin itself if you
look at vanity that pumps old coins and
by vanity i mean stuff like
you know what pumps an altcoin staking
we're getting staking we're burning
tokens uh we are launching liquidity
mining we are launching this
we're doing a partnership with some
random project all these things lead to
a pump right
it all takes inspirations from bitcoins
event like halving right even like
halving is for like once in a four years
it takes place which makes bitcoin
extremely bullish and that event is what
gives inspiration to all coins to start
doing stuff as well
i've completely gone off course to
whatever question you were asking me
unfortunately no it's fine no it's fine
i think it was great um
you know you went into openings and what
pumps oakland i think that's great i was
i actually started asking you just about
like ethics and longevity and um you
know staying honest to your audience um
and only taking on you know only sort of
working with projects um where you
actually see value
um but but i i feel like i feel like we
covered it um
you're
writing a book am i allowed to say that
yeah yeah i'm working on it i said it
all right let's hear it so shash is
writing a book can you tell us about it
so i'm trying to figure out more from an
economics perspective of how how
altcoins work and trying to talk more
about the altcoin perspective how you
can invest in them how to look at it
from a short term long term perspective
uh how how to even see it from so here's
the thing right we're all futurists
how to become a futurist is
is what i think everybody should be
wanting to do right
you put this stuff right it blushes me
and then i can't think anymore like
nobody gives me compliments like this
man guys this is a shash is pure gold we
need more of those words
yeah
sorry guys
i need this stuff and my brain stops
working because it's too much compliment
i just thought i was all about good
looks but nobody cared about my brains
when i come to your chat and now it
seems like i have brains as well so
amazing sorry sorry sorry so go on we're
all futurists tell us about your book
yeah so i've been writing it for a while
now and i want to kind of like just put
out my thoughts and make it easy for
people to sort of
have a long-term understanding of the
space one of one of the biggest problems
in this space is that
every
every group of people they try to make
it very
they try to build sometimes animosity
amongst each other but there is no
animosity right like people who own
bitcoin can own ethereum can own
everything so there is no like oh silica
is better than elrond or
you know like corn network is better
than ripple and this and that there is
no ripple versus bitcoin in fact
each coin sort of complements the rest
so in my book i'm trying to kind of talk
about how you can cut through that
and focus on how you should be
looking at the space grow yourself as an
individual and grow your
portfolio smartly i'm still here my
camera just switches off after 30
minutes hang on there we go i'm here
wow
yeah it's annoying
so how you can grow your portfolio how
you can navigate the space what else can
we expect
uh that's it the rest you'll have to
read the book right like
when's it so so what's the name of the
book and when's it coming out
uh i
i'm not telling you anything right now
that's everything is gonna come out in
due time
okay it's really exciting like it's not
it's not that exciting my book is not
going to do anywhere close to
uh most of the books it's just something
i'm doing because it's a bucket list
thing for me it won't be that exciting
trust me
i'm going to get it i'm excited so where
can people follow you everybody's been
asking for your twitter um
how can people follow you and how can
they follow upcom buzz
it's nothing to do with porn but my
twitter is called shash
xxx right yeah why
i have no idea i just i don't thought
like shawsh wasn't available then charge
x wasn't available i didn't want a
number on it i didn't want to write like
each shash or crypto i find that a
little weird so i just wrote like xxx
like just like that and
yeah i didn't know i will have a
following personally as well so
yeah i didn't bother so much it's
nothing to do with porn frankie
so guys go follow shash on twitter um
follow altcoinbuzz and check out their
youtube channel um they cover all um
really really exciting projects projects
that i should have gotten into but i
didn't because i'm silly um but now i'm
getting into them so i'm just basically
listening to what shash says and then
doing my own research because one should
always do that and then um and then
investing basically um so shash is so
good to have you on do you have any
final words do you have any last i know
you've been speaking for nearly an hour
but go on any any last words you'd like
to say
yeah i think the one thing i would like
to say is not like the most fun thing
that needs to be said is that
one thing is for sure is that bear
market is for buying
and bull market is for selling right
so if you've taken profits you're making
money
start taking out your profits if you've
done 2x 3x 5x start taking your returns
back now is not the time to invest more
than you can afford to lose that time
was last year when everybody was crying
uh now is the time to really really not
go crazy things are extremely euphoric
market has gone completely nuts right
now and i'm not a financial advisor but
as a friend i can tell you guys that
they
look at it long term there will be
hundreds of opportunities that will come
towards you people will be crippling
about crypto and saying it's garbage in
two years from now again it's bound to
happen that's the opportunity for you to
get in so think long term you buy too
much now and then you lose money on it
is like the last thing you really want
to do so be careful out there have fun
learn as much as you can and
the stuff that you buy even if they
correct keep on holding because that's
how much you should believe in it so
that's like
me trying to be wise there you know just
trying to be little
mature which isn't my style though
no i think it's great all right people
always forget you know bear markets
really are for buying people always get
afraid during crashes and things like
that but i for one am certainly going to
go all in and once the bear market is
confirmed that's the that's the risk
that's the level of risk i'm ready i'm
willing and ready to take um i can't do
it now because like you said it's too
euphoric and everything's at the top so
i won't take that kind of risk um but
shash i want to thank you so much it's
been so great to have you on um your
knowledge is just
like invaluable honestly
no it's pretty is that the word
invaluable
maybe is that interesting
it's value less
but no value less is like saying that it
has no value like it's zero right yeah
so invaluable is correct right
yeah but but last thing also i'd really
like to tell this to everyone as well
which i always tell find something to do
in crypto really this space is not going
anywhere this space is gonna go
really really high there is so much to
do so much money to be made get busy
right leah started her channel you guys
should start you know youtube channels
or start writing content start talking
about what you like getting your friends
involved start working for an
organization that you like there is a
need for thousands and thousands and
hundreds of thousands of people in the
crypto space literally there are so many
opportunities besides just investing so
get on get busy and there's and have fun
yeah
there you go guys thank you so much for
watching
pleasure to have you and we'll see you
all again next week have a great weekend
[Applause]
[Music]